all right Kenny red Kenny uh where'd you
grow up where you from originally
Oakland California East Oakland DPS
Oakland and tell me about your family
had brought your parents growing up as a
kid yeah well my mom my mother my mother
deceased she passed in 1979 when she was
37 and uh my real dad uh he passed away
too you know saying I mean and then we
didn't have much of a relationship but I
mean I knew about him you know I'm a
junior you know seeing but uh guess
where I come from DPS opening the ghetto
but you lost your mama hell real I was
18 I just turned 18 and how was your
childhood rough trying to come up out
together fighting to get up out together
you know and you left home and when
aren't your honor what age well laughter
well I have been running the street but
after my mom passed though um I got to
running around and you don't stand
trying to see what I'm a being do what
I'm gonna do you know and beauty and see
what I was gonna try to be you know
become did you have role models around
that we're kind of showing you the game
and stuff like that you know yeah you
know well my friend mass-to-charge you
know my friend mastercharge taught me to
game how to hustle and my friend gangsta
Brown gave me the game of the Pippin you
know I'm saying I want to I want to be
like both of them so I just combine it
into one you don't say so I came out one
of the greatest pimps and players that
ever lived you know I'm saying your kids
yup ain't that one five girl I mean five
boys and three girls and you're at your
runner ISM you know I just have one
that's graduate I got one motor go up so
seven to graduate I got one more to go
and so you really got going as a lay
team yeah I'll start wife started
pimping I started pimping at 18 years
old the first well the first real
prostitute I had was 18 years old how
did that happen
um a lot of the guys tell me that the
girls choose them well I mean that's
what I mean that's how I go
the girl that I had that girl I had came
across and everything you know I was
telling her how I go and I started I was
hanging out with some of my friends my
friend uh international blue a show kind
of gave me the game show how I go and he
knocked me for the girl I took took her
and took her off the Las Vegas and
everything so he tricked me out of my
boots I told I said you're the first one
that ever knocked me for a [ __ ] but you
guess what it won't happen no mo is that
part of the game is the just the robbing
John's tricks for of their money as well
as having sex for money well I mean they
looking for something and the girl
looking for something you don't want to
stand so the chick might want it on the
chick just try to get up money quick as
she can you don't want to say it but I
mean so if he put herself out there what
she can get is she gonna get it
officially if she ain't got nothing to
do with that's just like you
finance some money in front of your
building you gonna look for the person
that I can give it back to him what you
gonna keep it and pay your bills and the
sex is almost a distraction yeah
so how many girls would you have in your
stable like when you first started oh
when I first when I first came out I had
number one and then you know start
graduating two three four five you know
saying leave them of the most the most
females I've had at one time was like
eight maybe nine you know what I'm
saying
sometimes you can't cut you can't count
the fly-by-night though you know on
seeing the more that just came and go
you know and is there I think do you use
intimidation and force to get the girls
to come in or use like no no no no you
know the Copart about that's what they
always say oh he forced it you know a
lot of the square people that don't know
about the game that's the first thing
they say is oh he forced her to do deer
so he making it do it oh he manipulate
it but they felt it realized most of the
chick was already working already you
know what I'm saying
but ain't no way in the world I'm gonna
take somebody and make them do something
because I'm not gonna let nobody make me
do something that I don't want to do you
know what I'm saying if this is what you
were doing when you came you know so how
can they be mad you know and at what
races are you Russell black bike kandi
strike anybody but their body any soul
but a shoe so yes execute girl yeah
yeah my my woman you're a prostitute is
like your wife is your everything you
know say for a real pimp these other
yesterday they tell oh no I don't have
sex what else she just worked for being
out at you know a bunch of [ __ ] so
they make it hard for a real pimp and
her eric drexler drugs are part of the
picture no I mean you know a little weed
or something like that you know Sam what
happens if one of your girls gets a
little out of line
oh she got two good chicks you got you
know I'm saying up to tell her you know
respect you know say respect is big I
read my respect before I have my money
their laws have changed a lot yeah to
make your what you're doing much more
dangerous right yeah a whole lot a whole
lot they want to be buck rogers date for
something that somebody else want to do
you know I'm saying the game was not the
same my mo it didn't change the whole
lot see you've done prison time yeah
yeah for the offenses Oh money lines did
you have a choice for money laundering
and uh taking a minor across the state
lines what they see it where the
personality traits that that needs to to
succeed well you got to change you got
to change with the time you know saying
you got to have an understanding it's
not the olden days it's the frozen days
and the golden days you know what I'm
saying you got to its not compromising
but you got to you know it's about
respect and what qualities you look for
in a woman the best you know what's in
the best that it could satisfy a man
like he ain't never been satisfied
before you know what personality trait
do you have that it is the most valuable
for what you do well I have a whole lot
of but the number one is you know saying
I'm gonna treat you like I want to be
treated you know saying and the Bible
states that treat people the way you
want to be treated so that's me
what's the longest one of your girls has
been with you alone was that we had well
the loans I've had a female would be and
the game was like maybe about like five
or six years you know I'm saying yeah
you know that you know I go they come
and go he's been your favorite whatnot
anybody who walked through the door with
the
his bankroll down was the favor what are
you proudest of in your life
what are you proud of stuff whatever
what am i proud is up I'm proud I'm
proud of that I have eight kids and then
I'm a good dad you don't say that and uh
I have seven kids that graduated I got
one more to go and I've been in my kid's
life enough and I'm proud that I'm not a
dope fiend and I'm not embarrassing to
my kids so do you think the the
relationship a prostitute has with a
pimp is similar to that you know maybe
she's looking to replace the
relationship she had with her father or
didn't have with her father well it's
it's like somewhat but most of the times
they call you daddy no no no I've never
allowed my female to call me daddy you
know say because I feel like you got
your own dad you know I'm your man you
know what I'm saying I didn't like to
call them you dad you know yeah call me
Kenny Rhea
yeah the one anomaly so you're you're
based in Las Vegas now yeah that's why I
live in now and the girls will work
through the casinos or online or how
does it go down well I mean with a well
how I go now and you know they they go
everywhere you know Sam well you know
the traffic travel around the country
no I haven't I haven't been nowhere
lately but I mean but I have no you
don't say I'll be I go you don't say if
I have to but other than that though
I'll just you know just do me I'm riding
motorcycles I got a hobby I have fun you
know I'm getting old now you know things
ain't the same and the girls are make
how much money tonight
we're not apenas you know so yeah it
could be from the sky's the limit you
know I'm saying it could be from zero it
could be a a million yeah it's the sky's
the limit you know saying that you never
can't say you know I never seen nobody
who'll just tell them to go get
something and come home I mean leave not
me what's the craziest thing you've seen
it all your years of doing this the
craziest thing
is when I was in Hollywood back you know
like 1981 and uh it was just good pimp I
forgot his name and his girl left him
and you know kind of drove him crazy and
everything I was young and the game kind
of drove me crazy and everything we came
and then I come back like 10 15 years
later and the man was still on the same
corner waiting on waiting on the chick
to come back yeah well how would you
feel if one of your sons or daughters
decide to follow in dad's footsteps
well I got a son is in prison now you
know I'm saying yeah you know saying for
different allegations that they said
about him and everything you know what
I'm saying and you know when you owe
that sex trafficking related stuff yeah
yeah all that yeah the whole the whole
nine yards they want to try to give him
life you know he got like nine years you
know I'm saying and uh but if they
really if they wanted you know I'm
saying I mean it's just like being a
football coach you know what I'm saying
I mean I'm the coach trying to make the
players better you see them saying so I
mean that would be my thing you know
what to say I mean I don't cook I don't
condone it but if that's what they gonna
do
I mean what do I supposed to do
especially if I come from the streets
ain't like that I've got a white collar
shirt on and a tie you know what I'm
saying so I'll come from the streets so
I had to give it to them yeah they never
had that you grew up in an Oakland
doctor lawyer obviously no no I come
from wasn't no doctors and lawyer with
pimps drug dealers gangsters and killers
you know say and basically basically
mostly all the pimps that's what he come
from that's what they see coming out the
door you know yeah that affects a young
man's decision of what direction believe
well I mean it's the fast money you know
what I'm saying but you know through my
years and everything one thing that I
have learned that there is no shortcut
in life ain't no shortcut of nowadays
you know I try to give you know when I
got to give you some game I'm gonna give
it to you and tell you the truth I
really go you know not just oh I love
all the glory that's behind it no you
got to know the ins and outs you know
the truth about it you know but if what
did your your parents say to you and
your
and you were making this career choice
did they know did they know no because
no because it because this way it was it
wasn't what you lost your mom Aditi yeah
it wasn't my career choice back then I
just want to just would be a you know
just a young player you know saying be
in the street have me a couple of
girlfriends and you know saying it give
me a job I was thinking like a square
back you know saying when I was young
you know yeah and your kids knew what
you did when they were earlier younger
you know number here I never hear
nothing from my kids and I got painted a
beautiful with kids you know never had
nothing for Mike here well I don't care
what it was you know but do you think
the most misunderstood the most
misunderstood thing about this world
that the pimp prostitute world that if
Outsiders don't understand because they
always talking about you manipulator you
forces somebody or you you got dope and
all that kind of stuff and I understand
the way that they feel because that's
the stuff that they see like the stuff
they sell on Jerry Springer that's a
bunch of bootleg and all that kind of
stuff but you know they the first
anything is a gym oh she didn't get no
money or someone beat or else someone
put her on drugs and something like that
and just don't go like that you know and
I wouldn't condone let you know I'm
saying I could even have no friend that
do something like that to a woman or
associate or something like that you
know insane but that's the first thing
they always think oh he beaten there or
he giving her drugs you know I'm saying
or dragging her down the street or he
making her go do stuff now you can't
make nobody gonna do nothing they got
people some of my friends I got a friend
that's in jail gave 174 years and had a
girl had a few girls and one for nine
years and everything and she talked
about oh he made me go out of town he
said if I didn't do this he was gonna
kill my family and well opti well you
could have been went to the police a
long time ago and take nine years you
know how can you make somebody do
something for nine years and this is
what these people put out there and send
a man to the finish it if you notice if
you do your homework
you would notice every pimp that catch a
case they always talking about
he had an underage female every pair
look look it up you see every pimp there
getting arrested he always had an
underage female that he took across the
state line come on laughs hey
railroading people you know they they
know the truth should the politicians
they buy [ __ ] you know
what's what's the biggest change in the
game since you started because the laws
have changed the style has changed well
the biggest thing the changes they make
some code so call Kim's make some code
deals with the girls now you know say
they get to keep most of the money half
for the money
all of the money he smells what I'm
saying they just happened to say oh
that's my that's my girl over there
because she had a prostitute that get
money or she might be reputable or
something you know I said or she might
give you know she go get the money and
give him some allows you know I said
it's just not the way it was you know
I'm saying I had to have all the money
not some of the money not half of the
money all the money and what does the
girl get out of it protection no no it's
not I mean it's not just protection but
because the prostitute that's my woman
you know what I'm saying so I'm gonna
make sure that she straights you don't
say but but if if she go to New York if
she go to New York somewhere and go meet
her at Rick or John over there a trick
or whatever how can I protect her if I'm
if I'm if I'm in California and she in
New York I can't protect it from there
you see what I'm saying
I she so she have to learn how to
protect herself when she oh yeah she
good cars clothes you know saying the
whole night everything you know what I'm
saying is it's not it's just it's just
not no oh no uh-uh
well just let me give her this or
something like that you nowadays the way
it is now you got to treat a prostitute
like like you know like she your wife
you know saying as I go you know it
ain't Oh [ __ ] get up go to work or get
dressed in their exam a real prostitute
you ain't got to tell her she already
know to get up and go get dressed and go
get some money and leave it on the
dresser when she come in you know I'm
saying nah [ __ ] nowadays Cathy I'll be
saying they be arguing and fighting you
know I'm saying it it ain't Oh macaroni
data then it turned into domestic you
know want to say it's more domestic now
you know yeah and that that that this
lifestyle and marriage probably don't
work well together right no no no I mean
no no I mean well if you got you if you
got that kind of chick you know yeah I
mean you know and she cooling you know
and she and uh and she's been in the
game you know sandy I mean II I mean
this you pretty much know what's what
you know what I'm saying I mean you know
I got some fighters now you know saying
Oh order to me you know send the hair
chick like
35 years you know what I'm saying hey
what else you gonna do you know what I'm
saying I'm Sami Sami so that's what they
chose but me I'm still me I'm still
industry you're still active I'm still
I'm still in the street I plead the
fifth but I'm still in the street all
right Kay thank you so much for talk
about that
all right thanks artists okay thanks a
lot
[Music]